this is um what number is this this is
23 D
because there was no question 24 whoops
on 23 D um you guys you guys no one
knows that I was too busy reading this
ridiculous article there's no 24 me um
23 D you guys got destroyed on this
question ok 4 marks discuss social and
ethical issues so I'm working for for
two positives to your negatives you
scored 59 % as a class on that question
right now again I felt like oh man I
can't think of 4 issues four issues
really not to show you how many issues
are there let's come up shall we
I've got pluses for positive issues
right and my sister so we got one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven that's all I could think of okay
um I could probably put down a few more
these are what I thought of I could put
down a few more if I went through your
papers and say oh there's someone
someone thought of one that I didn't
think of okay so this might be like 12
to 15 and I was looking for four okay
they did you did have to give me both
sides okay and that's why you know
pluses and minuses okay but let's think
about these so for instance this lost
cards business hmm I'm putting this one
right up first I'm glad that um that
it's hard at first because most people
said oh no people are gonna lose their
cards this is gonna be the worst issue
ever it's a positive not a negative
think about it okay number one lost card
what's the alternative if the cards in
you just lost money right guess what
lost my knees worse than a lost card
right cuz once you lose money you can't
cancel that money but money's just gone
right but a card like a credit card or
over card that kind of thing I lose that
where's it going I just ring them up and
I say can you cancel my car and give me
a new one it all of my money my credit
is intact okay now some of you mentioned
oh yeah people are gonna get all these
privacy details from you that kind of
thing probably you'll get some right but
think about really what are you gonna
store in the car probably the car ID
number right maybe the actual balance of
the card but probably not the balance is
probably stored in the cloud right
because it needs to get updated every
single time
right and also if you cancel the card
you can't remotely cancel like it
doesn't have wireless transmission or
something like that like a phone so
probably every time you swipe in front
of a card reader right it's going to
read your balance off the servant they
have which has all of your data on it
and they'll say ok this person has
enough that's fine thank you so lots of
card really it should be it should be a
positive issue because losing a card is
better than losing with it you can fix
that quite easily other things like
increase the effectiveness most of you
said that because of the faster and if
you've ever been on those prepaid buses
in the city it's amazing like people get
on tick-tick-tick they're like there's
20 people on the bus just like that
right whereas that would have taken well
an average transaction on a bus you
think about it you got to get your money
out pay it get some change back and then
they have to shuffle away so maybe 30 to
45 seconds so that was a big one most
people mentioned that reduces the need
to actually carry physical cash apart
from transport or not reduce security
risk most people I think one person I
read actually said this but this is a
big one right security at the station
not for people like passengers that's a
big deal think of how much money goes in
and out of a train station every day
it's a lot of money right that's why
there's so much security there but um
having cards reduces that reason okay
now let's see here I think that yeah um
this here
support engineers hired to maintain
system this is really the flip side of
one of the best issues you can pick up
often is changing nature of work as some
of you mention it but you only mentioned
the negative so people are gonna lose
jobs that's true but some people are
going to gain jobs
- right so changing nature's of work
with technology almost always goes both
ways it's a bit like privacy right if
you give up privacy that's a negative
right but you get the positive more once
people know that data value they can
serve you better because we know stuff
about you right so we can tailor our
service to you so always pick out those
issues that go both ways okay that gives
you the same number of points issues
in a quicker way you don't have to waste
three sentences the negatives wait you
had pretty crazier than they do some
some of you arou Lee said negatives
right in which case I could give you a
maximum of two marks because it's
discussed so you've got to get both
sides okay but I think most of you okay
now this one here I I'm putting this in
I didn't I don't think I deducted marks
for memory if I did shut me up on it
then I might be able to fix that up but
it's it's more about thoughtfulness kind
of thing for you right so that a partner
transport is a government organization
and a lot of people say oh well now the
government knows your bank details right
that's terrible and they didn't know
your Beatty test before really like most
of the government aren't thinking of
likes a tax many care if you're getting
rebates and that kind of thing which
most people do because most people Bob
build when they see the GP they don't
pay like a GP privately right um they
know your bait details they know a lot
about you write all this stuff about the
NSA like oh dude they've got most of all
ready okay the government already owns
this kind of data about you so don't
overstep your your case right and think
about what they already know and don't
rehearse